the Trump administration's newest
immigration policy will affect hundreds
of thousands of legal immigrants the
public charge rule will make it more
difficult for low-income immigrants to
become permanent US residents the
administration says it is only
implementing a law that Congress passed
23 years ago Weiser Jiang is near the
president's New Jersey Golf Club where
he's on vacation
so what's the what's the goal of this
policy oh good morning Gail you know
President Trump has already enforced a
lot of aggressive steps against illegal
immigration but these new rules bolster
his long-standing belief that legal
immigrants should be merit-based and
hardliners in his administration like
Stephen Miller who have crafted much of
the immigration policy have long pushed
for these changes that target poor
immigrants throughout our history
self-reliance has been a core principle
in America acting director of
Citizenship and Immigration Services Ken
Cuccinelli announced it will be harder
for legal immigrants to become permanent
residents if they are likely to use a
public benefit such as Medicaid food
stamps and subsidized housing to ensure
that our immigration system is bringing
people to join us as American citizens
as legal permanent residents first who
can stand on their own two feet the
administration argues that whether
someone will be primarily dependent on
the government for support is already a
factor in their status but the new rules
will put more of an emphasis on a
person's financial well-being about
three hundred eighty two thousand people
will be subject to the public charge
test every year basically have to choose
between ensuring that their families are
healthy that they have the nutrition
that they need and just overall
well-being or be separated and
potentially be denied the ability to
remain permanently here Mary Alina hing
capilla is the executive director of the
National Immigration Law Center out of
all of the immigration policies this is
actually the one that will have the most
deepest widest and longest term impact
probably for decades to come despite the
administration's claim that large
numbers of non citizen immigrants have
taken advance
of our generous public benefits recent
statistics show that they make up only
six point five percent of Medicaid
participants and eight point eight
percent of those who receive food stamps
the new rules are set to go into effect
on October 15th but they will likely
face plenty of legal challenges and end
up in court and there are exceptions for
people who already have green cards
refugees asylum seekers pregnant women
and children and some members of the
military Tony all right we sure thank
you very much